wie groß ist ein schwimme ich nehme an
dass er damit meinen penis meint und
leute in zeiten von minecraft tsunamis
und für 200 euro an den arsch getreten
und an das männliche geschlechtsteil
fassen hat man auf youtube doch manchmal
den wunsch so ein bisschen in die eigene
zurückzukehren als es noch wissen
anderen content auf youtube haben
dementsprechend machen wir heute einfach
mal ein zeitsprung zurück in die
vergangenheit und ich gehe auf die
fragen ein die mir auf twitter gestellt
habe wunderschön dabei schon der anfang
ich habe euch gebeten mir nicht fragen
wie wie bist du auf deinen namen
gekommen zu stellen da kann man jetzt
natürlich überlegen welche frage 60
prozent aller fragen ausgemacht hat
genau wie bist du auf deinen namen
gekommen weil die frage stellen war
natürlich ein paar namen dabei die ich
schon kannte ein paar andere habe ich so
bisher noch nicht gehört darunter auch
die erste pfeiler heute die comfort
winzer kannst du auf meinen nacken
kommen ich sag jetzt mal nichts deutet
er ja mal bildlich vor wie ich auf gs
nacken komme also an der stelle die
gäste die ok ist die kaffeekasse
vergessen oder schlecht los mal vor
kommt mir ist alles okay willst du den
leuten so heißt der genfer katze jedes
mal aber ist die cd aufnahme alter
[ __ ] dann wäre der vermisste sie
eine brücke glaubst du dass du noch
erzählen ja ein youtube macht laufe ich
an der stelle nicht ja also material
schock ich plane mein leben auch so dass
ich keine ausgaben habe die ich jetzt
mit dem was jetzt schon alle an geld zu
denken kann beispielsweise sage mal ich
kaufe jetzt ein r8 v10 plus für die
ausstellung 220.000 euro okay das würde
ich einfach nicht machen leute das will
ich einfach nicht machen für mich ist
youtube so und sich an diese plattform
da ich so oft alter ist so gestört so
wenn youtube kein bock hat will einen
rhythmus geändert wird das jetzt
menschen mit neuen schwarzen lederjacken
geblockt werden auf youtube will man
kann doch jetzt gelöscht
lynn franco würdest du deine lippen
kanal löschen
3 herr plan für eine millionen euro oder
so auf jeden fall die leute eine million
euro bis sie wieder man braucht um eine
million euro zu verdienen also eine
million euro safe und dann einfach am
nächsten tag einen knall dann wenn er
für euch jetzt noch nicht komplett ist
kann er wird also keiner drüber perfekt
übrigens leute die lederjacke habe ich
mir vor drei stunden erst gekauft das
verstörte klamotten ausgabe aller zeiten
bleibt mal in die kommentare mit der
pflege zu hause
hahaha lustig ist er wieder lustig hatte
deswegen die ihre füße nicht lust hätte
das gibt es jetzt auch mal richtig laut
unter den scheibenwischer alter ylvi rs
käfig die fragt selbstverständlich hier
natürlich auch weil ich sehr viele junge
zuschauer haben eine komplett jugend
freie frage und zwar fix du gerne an
dieser stelle möchte ich einfach gerne
um das einfach besser auszudrücken und
weil ich das besser nicht in worte
verpacken könnte einen guten kumpel von
mir zitierten tony cragg richtig gern da
will ich für einfach und lässt du dir
keinen bart wachsen sieht aber scheiße
bei mir aus was wirst du wirst bist du
und wie gefällt es dir also ich wäre
immer noch wirtschaftswissenschaften bin
jetzt kurz vor der bachelor weil die
kommt jetzt demnächst muss meine
bachelorarbeit schreiben so ja die
ersten zwei jahre darf ich nicht sogar
ein wohlgefühl mit der zeit fehlt dann
eine pause gemacht habe gearbeitet ein
praktikum gemacht kann man zurück und
habe gesehen als arbeiten richtig
scheiße von dem bei youtube macht und
das ist über einen ultra des
supertalents und da hatte ich das rocker
studium die abfahrt hättest du auch mal
lust einen song raus zu bringen und
denkst du dass das ausreichend talent
kei nen scheiß wieder eine letzten tagen
geistern wir die ganze zeit irgendwelche
web nämlich den kopf also ich hätte
eigentlich mal brauchen wir so ein rap
song zu machen aber das wäre dann auf
jeden fall nicht so emotional
wer über die ausbildung die grad läuft
dann ist also als angeber sachen so ich
habe voll ist hätte auto bekommt wird
sich der fall ist eigentlich nicht lose
freiheit falls youtube irgendwann nicht
mehr läuft was machst du dann ganz
einfach ich habe jetzt ein studium so
dass sich ordentlich durch habe
ordentlich bluten wenn youtube nicht
mehr läuft dann studie ich einfach
weitermachen ein master dann auch fertig
und dann arbeite ich einfach nur meinen
job müsse überlegen leute was mache ich
wenn es vorbei ist dass youtube wieder
fragt was willst du mal erreichen so in
die richtung lebensziel eine million
autos viele leute fragen ja auch beim
murger konnte man vorgekommen ist alles
geplant leute hawks kommen
wahrscheinlich demnächst in den nächsten
wochen heißt wenn ihr besorgt haben
wollt haltet euch bereit da gehst du
gasball infos und ihr könnt das alkohol
und ist nämlich kommt auch spätestens zu
weihnachten wieder für die weihnachten
dass ihr das unsere röhrenjeans baum
legen könnt seit 98
da hab ich für zwar anders aber nicht
fassen aber es war okay leute eine frage
haben doch das hat mir echt lange
überlegt ob ich die mit rein nehmen soll
aber dann habe ich gedacht okay scheiß
drauf hab ich erstmal raus und zwar von
ofk ein doppel
wie groß ist denn schwimme ich nehme an
dass er damit meinen penis mann und
warum reden youtube eigentlich nicht
über so was so ich hause sag mal raus
leute
es sind ganz einfach über 1,2 millionen
kilometer